Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus wo erreiche ich dich wo
steckst du gerade was ja immer gleichen
Ort aber ausnahmsweise mal weil ich bin
zur Zeit doch relativ viel unterwegs
okay und machst was
viele Gespräche gerade ja
Podiumsdiskussionen okay gut ja
verschiedene Foren an der Uni und so
weiter viele Gespräche das heißt ihr
tauscht Argumente aus auf der Bühne ihr
streitet euch ihr kriegt euch richtig in
die Wolle oder wie läuft das ab ja also
mal ein bisschen über diese
Debattenkultur Spielen über dieses
Phänomen das AH alle sofort beleidigt
sind und man sagt einen Satz und tritt
schon jemandem wieder auf die Füße ohne
ist aber zu wollen das heißt die
Intention ist eigentlich nebensächlich
spielt keine Geige sondern irgendjemand
schreit sofort auf und sagt ich bin
jetzt beleidigt ja und das andere ist so
dass man dass man miteinander redet und
auch streitet und dass man vielleicht
jemanden sogar gut finden kann aber
trotzdem
Meinung nicht teilt ja dass man das
Argument versteht und sagt pass auf ich
kapiere dich aber ich teile diese
Meinung nicht aber nur in dem Moment wo
du sagst ich verstehe dein Argument ich
kann nicht nachvollziehen bist du schon
wieder auf der falschen Spur
ja also diese Gespräche die haben viele
Facetten du hast ja ganz viele davon
schon genannt also mit dem beleidigt
sein fällt mir auch auf ne also ich kann
mich gar nicht daran erinnern in
früheren Diskussionen oder oder
Debatten Auseinandersetzung auch im
Fernsehen oder so dass da hier jemals
jemand beleidigt war und wenn er das war
hat er das nicht gezeigt ja aber das ist
souverän war beleidigt zu sein heute
egal was man sagt es gibt Millionen von
Menschen die unglaublich versessen
darauf sind beleidigt zu sein und man
kann ihm das aber nicht sagen weil wenn
man sie dafür kritisiert sind sie schon
wieder beleidigt die elegant ist da hat
ein Gespräch abzuwürgen ist beleidigt zu
sein oder alles weitere ebenfalls
beleidigt zu reagieren ja ich werde
interessanterweise werde ich das so oft
gefragt kannst du gar nicht vorstellen
wie häufig diese Frage kommt auch nach
Sendungen wo es mal ein bisschen höher
hergeht oder so dass Leute mich dann
fragen und sag mal wie war das hinterher
war sie beleidigt war er beleidigt habt
die noch miteinander geredet oder oder
gab es dann richtig Stress und so weiter
und die Überraschung ist dann immer sehr
sehr groß wenn ich sage nee wir haben
hinterher noch sehr nett
zusammengesessen und der ganze Weile
noch geplaudert über dieses und jenes
und alles mögliche und unter merkst Du
genau diese diese Attitüde ja die da
sagt mir jeder aber der muss doch
beleidigt gewesen sein das kann der sich
doch nicht bitten lassen denn selbst
wenn er beleidigt war und selbst wenn es
ihn genervt hat dann macht es doch den
Profi aus dass er sagt okay ich ich gehe
aber souverän damit um
aber die die das ist nicht so richtig
drehen das haben wir nicht mehr weil es
ist einfach ein unglaublich
gesellschaftlich akzeptierter Zustand
beleidigt zu sein
und das weiß es früher nicht gewesen und
deswegen spielt das so eine große Rolle
wann hat denn das angefangen Richard was
willst du zu sagen ihr kommt das
ziemlich neu vor also ich würde schon
sagen das ist was was nicht älter ist
als ein Jahrzehnt und ich habe das
Gefühl dass sie sich auch in den letzten
Jahren noch mal von Jahr zu Jahr
verstärkt hat und womit hat das zu tun
was denkst du
dass er etwas damit zu tun dass es
akzeptiert ist dass man beleidigt ist
also dass man in Anrecht darauf hat
beleidigt zu sein weil man sich
vielleicht falsch auf sein Geschlecht
angesprochen fühlt oder dass man ohne
das Gefühl hat einer Minderheit an zu
gehören die despektierlich behandelt
worden ist und so weiter die Debatten
und die Diskurse die sind ja richtig
dass wir die für das ist ja richtig dass
wir heute anders wollen Minderheiten
reden oder viele Minderheiten
zumindestens also das früher gemacht
haben das sind alles Fortschritte aber
die führen eben auf der anderen Seite
eben auch zu erhöhten sind sie bilitäten
und dieses beleidigt sein ist ein
Ausdruck unserer
hochsensibilitätskultur ja die Frage ist
immer wo führt uns das hin ich habe
neulich mitgekriegt du bist dafür
kritisiert worden dass du dass du das
Denken die Art und Weise sich mit
Argumenten zu beschäftigen von Karl
Lauterbach lobst ja ohne aber dessen
Meinung zu teilen ja also ich habe ja
hier im Podcast ein ganz ausdrücklich
gesagt ich halte Karl Lauterbach den ich
persönlich kenne für ein integeren
intelligenten und gebildeten Menschen so
und das würde ich auch jederzeit
wiederholen
ich jede aber der sich so ein bisschen
damit beschäftigt hat was ich so im
Laufe der Zeit über Corona gesagt habe
und über Corona denke weiß dass ich sehr
häufig mit Karl Lauterbach nicht einer
Meinung bin
und das sind zwei Dinge die passen in
meinem Kopf gut zusammen ich stelle mir
mal vor ich würde nur die Leute für
intelligent und integer gehalten die
genau meiner Meinung sind
das wäre ja absolut merkwürdig weil
umgekehrt all die Leute für besonders
toll halte also besonders schlimm halte
die nicht meiner Meinung teilen und das
stimmt eben nicht also die Frage ob ich
vor jemanden Respekt habe und ob ich den
für moralische Ordnung heilte ist
unabhängig von der Frage ob er in seinen
Meinung mit mir übereinstimmt oder nicht
und wenn ich jetzt so viele Gespräche
habe wie in letzter Zeit da frage ich
mich natürlich auch manchmal selber ne
also warum warum macht man das warum
unterhält man sich jetzt mit dem warum
macht man das zu diesem Thema und das
Interessante ist immer wenn ich das
Gespräch so ein bisschen langweilig
finde dann ist es mir wichtig Recht zu
behalten aber wenn ich den
Gesprächspartner so richtig interessant
finde dann ist eigentlich mein
Hauptinteresse an dem Gespräch was dazu
zu lernen
und da ist es ausgesprochen günstig sich
mit Menschen zu unterhalten die eben
nicht in allem schon immer die genau
gleiche Meinung haben weil das ist das
langweiligste überhaupt ja total also
ich meine das kann man auch
Selbstgespräch machen man kann sich ein
paar Bier kippen und kann unausgesetzt
mit sich selbst einverstanden sein da
braucht man nicht jemand anders führen
das ganze Thema diese sogenannten
wahrheitsfragen so rund um Themen wie
Identität Corona Klima Migration da gibt
es ja irgendwie sogar keine Zwischentöne
mehr es ist immer nur grau und es gibt
nur Wahrheit oder Lüge und dann wird das
so aufgeladen dass wir eigentlich auch
über Kompromisse gar nicht mehr reden
können und ich würde sagen das ist so
ein ja so ein neuer Kulturkampf der
Stadt findet das hatte Wolfgang vor
einiger Zeit so gesagt diese
Moralisierung des Diskurses das ist
total gefährlich und er hat interessante
These weil ich dich gerade fragte wann
das angefangen hat er sagt das hat ganz
viel mit Merkel zu tun mit 16 Jahren
Merkel
und sagt da da waren sozusagen bestimmte
Debatten ausdrücklich einfach nicht mehr
erwünscht politischer Streit und dann
meldete sich Wolfgang Bosbach zu Wort
den wir beide auch kennen sehr
interessant der der sagte wir haben
früher an der CDU unfassbar diskutiert
endlos endlos haben wir diskutiert aber
es ist dann zum Beispiel plötzlich um
die AFD ging da war dann irgendwie klar
pass auf liebe Leute hat keinen Zweck da
reden wir jetzt nicht mehr drüber weil
im Zweifel wenn die Leute lieber das
Original also lass uns die Themen erst
gar nicht anfassen ja dann kommen wir
gar nicht mehr in die Verlegenheit
überhaupt über diese über diese seltsame
AFD zu sprechen das heißt die die Frage
dass man einfach nur mal darüber
nachdenkt warum die AFD auch von Leuten
gewählt wird die nicht aus dem
rechtsextremen Milieu stammen ja also
dass man unterscheidet sozusagen
zwischen den Funktionären der AFD ruft
motiviert genau und ihren Wählern das
ist der große Unterschied und dass das
finde ich interessanten Punkt während
des und das sagt auch Bosbach in die
andere Richtung war das komischerweise
kein Problem also da hat er auch Merkel
nie ein Thema wenn es darum ging
sozusagen in die in die grüne Richtung
ja Themen zu übernehmen sich zur
Klimakanzlerin zu stilisieren und so
weiter das war komischerweise keine
Frage da galt dann plötzlich dieses
Argument dann wählen die Leute lieber
das Original galt da plötzlich nicht
mehr und das das ist ein interessante
Beobachtung finde ich es war sicherlich
richtig dass die merkelzeit die die Zeit
der großen gesellschaftlichen
Harmonisierung war ja und die CDU eine
Partei sein wollte die alles in Leitform
integriert ne also gerade nicht mit
irgendwelchen Positionen aus der Deckung
kommen wollte wo man Menschen mit
verschrecken oder verärgern kann oder
heftige Gegenwehr für bekommt sondern es
war so ein gleitendes mitschwingen mit
dem Zeitgeist und es ist ja richtig wenn
das das gesellschaftliche Klima ist was
Positives abgewinnen kann ne kann sagen
Deutschland ein friedliches glückliches
Land ja keine heftigen Debatten und so
dann hat man aber gesehen wie das so oft
ist wenn viele harmonisiert wird dass
ich unterschwellig eine Menge anschaut
und dass ich das dann irgendwann bricht
und es immer nur eine Frage der Zeit ist
wann sich das entsprechend artikuliert
und es ist auch schon richtig Parteien
lieben ja Streitkultur nicht ich
erinnere das war schon früher so obwohl
man mehr gestritten hat ja waren die
Parteien immer darauf bedacht Leute zu
haben die versuchen jeglichen Streit
innerhalb der Partei zu vermeiden also
herbert Wehner hatte den den den
Beinamen jetzt sucht meisten SPD muss
ich mal überlegen ich meine das
abgesehen davon dass dieses altmodische
Begriff der wunderbar zu einer Person
wie weder passte heute nicht mehr in die
Zeit passt es ging darum dass er ein
Dingden Idealisten ja die die Frau sind
austreiben sollte das war damit gemeint
damit die Partei pragmatisch bleiben
kann
und im Grunde genommen gibt es das Wort
Meister nicht mehr aber jeder ist
inzwischen Zuchtmeister seiner selbst
geworden ja man wagt sich nicht so weit
aus der Deckung weil die natürlich die
Medien darauf lauern ja jeden kleinen
defens in einer regierungsqualition in
einer Partei und so weiter zu einem
riesen Debakel aufzublasen das war zwar
früher auch so ne das hat ja Spiegel
gemacht seit es gibt aber das haben die
Parteien früher lockerer weggestecken
heute ist es immer wichtig dass man
irgendwie ein guten und geschlossenen
und einigen Eindruck macht das
Lieblingswort von Angela Merkel war ja
immer gemeinsam heute ist das
Lieblingswort von Annalena behrburg es
gibt keinen einzigen Beitrag nämlich
hier oder fünf Mal gemeinsam vorkommt
möchte also bei alledem immer sagen dass
man mit den anderen und in der Mitte
also man vermeidet alles was irgendwie
zu sehr nach Kante aussieht und das
provoziert die mit den Kanten die fühlen
sich da nicht mehr repräsentiert das ist
der Punkt und es gibt noch so eine Angst
dass es auch interessant der der
berüchtigte Applaus von der falschen
Seite ne gerade einiger Zeit hatten wir
Christian dörrt in den fdp-fraktions äh
Chef im Bundestag bei uns in der Sendung
der sich kritisch über Migration
geäußert hat das muss man vorausschicken
Christian dürr ist jemand der absolut
nicht im Verdacht steht irgendwie ein
rassistisches Resultat zu fliegen gar
nicht ganz im Gegenteil Christian dürr
ist einer der weiß ich aus anderen
Gesprächen schon zu seiner Zeit im
Landtag in Hannover immer sehr darum
bemüht war zu verstehen 25 15 2 16 ja
diese Jahre der der Migration der großen
mig schon zu verstehen wie geht es den
Leuten wo kommen die her was ist ihre
Motivation speziell nach Deutschland zu
kommen und der berichtete davon dass er
unter anderem mit einem Asylbewerber aus
Afrika darüber gesprochen hat was denn
seine Motivation sei ausgerechnet in
dieses kalte Land zu kommen in dem in
dem diese Sprache gesprochen wird die
für jemanden der nicht von hier ist sehr
schwer zu erlernen ist und so weiter und
der sagte zu ihm na ja also das hat ganz
offen ja Katzen
Naivität sagte einfach naja also bei uns
zu Hause erzählen die Leute dass
Deutschland das einzige Land ist indem
man dafür bezahlt wird nicht zu arbeiten
so das erzählt also das ist anekdotisch
und er sagte wir haben da offensichtlich
ein Problem mit mit dem Image dass wir
nach draußen verkörpern und so weiter
und wir müssen daran arbeiten dass das
anders wird und vor allen Dingen war
sein Plädoyer wie kriegen wir die Leute
stattdessen integriert und rein in
unserer in unserer Wertesystem und rein
in den Arbeitsmarkt wo wir sie so
dringend brauchen man kann direkt das
Totschlagargument ich meine Ulrike
Herrmann war's die sagte das geht ja gar
nicht das ist AFD sprechen
und wenn ich sozusagen an dem Punkten
nicht weitergemacht hätte mit der
Diskussion weil ich war schon darauf
gefasst dass dieses Totschlagargument
kommt dann wäre es an dem Punkt zu Ende
gewesen und wir hätten diese wurde dann
eine sehr gute Sendung über das Thema
Migration und Integration und unser
Asylsystem wenn ich das zugelassen hätte
dann wäre es an dem Punkt wieder
passiert gewesen wäre vorbei gewesen
kommst du mit dieser Keule und es ist
vorbei ja also wir würden wir regulieren
Debatten durch Buttons also wir kriegen
irgendwo was drauf und dann brauchen wir
uns damit nicht weiter
auseinanderzusetzen genau dann hat er
sein keines mal bekommen richtig und
damit reduzieren wir das über was wir
reden können und wie wir über etwas
reden können irgendwann bis zur
absoluten Unkenntlichkeit richtig na
also dann ist es wirklich nur noch so so
so ein kleiner Graubereich in der Mitte
über den überhaupt geredet werden kann
und dann auch immer ausgelegt worden
und das hat natürlich mit Streitkultur
und Debatten und alle dem was eine
deliberativen Demokratie gut zu Gesicht
steht nichts mehr zu tun das ist die
Gefahr die dahinter natürlich steckt ist
es nicht sogar so Richard dass man auch
das z.B auch so ein Ding dieser dieser
Rigorismus der der dahinter steckt ja
dieses ganz harte sofort ahnten wenn
irgendjemand etwas falsches sagt ich ich
erinnere mich und sehr bezeichnend für
direkt das neue Jahr erste Sendung
Friedrich Merz bei uns in der Sendung
und er sagt Paschas und es war sehr
interessant dann zu sehen was da
passiert ist war sofort oh er hat
Paschas gesagt das heißt wochenlang und
ehrlich gesagt bis heute Monate lang
dreht sich der Diskurs die ganze Zeit er
hat Paschas gesagt Achtung Friedrich
merzer Paschas gesagt jetzt muss man
einfach sagen
genau die ultimative Beleidigung ja
genau richtig ich aber ich wollte auch
was anderes hinaus ich wollte eigentlich
sagen
weitere Haltung oder andere
nierungsverkörpert sondern wir
unterstellen dass jemand böse ist ja
diese enorme Personalisierung in diesem
Debatten dass wir sagen wenn der nicht
meiner Meinung ist oder wenn der solche
Worte benutzt dann hat er sich verraten
dass er zu den schlechten gehört und
nicht zu den guten ja der der Punkt den
den ich gerade eben noch mal machen
wollte ist also es hilft der Debatte
überhaupt gar nicht ich finde man kann
zu Recht völlig zu Recht kritisieren
dieses Wort in dem Zusammenhang und auch
so pauschal und so weiter aber statt
über das Phänomen dahinter zu sprechen
und das ist übrigens Teil dieser dieses
neuen Kulturkampfes den ich auch
wirklich in der Sendung so erlebe und
vor allen Dingen interessanterweise
hinter den Kulissen wir reden dann nicht
mehr über das Phänomen dahinter wir
reden nicht mehr über das was
Lehrerinnen Lehrer
sagen was sie erleben im Unterricht
worüber sie sich beklagen was wirklich
ihre Themen sind und die sagen wir haben
natürlich ein Problem mit Jungs
zum Teil ein hochproblematisches
Frauenbild beispielsweise haben die auch
ein Problem damit haben etwas von mir
anzunehmen einfach nur deswegen weil ich
eine Frau bin weil ich eine Lehrerin bin
und das Interessante ist und und da
merkst du dass wir dann so
ungefährlichen Punkt sind noch mal kann
das pauschale kritisieren und das ist
auch in dieser Pauschalität auch
überhaupt nicht zutreffend aber ich
erlebe das hinter den Kulissen der
Sendung danach plötzlich Vertreter von
sehr weit links die die ganze liberale
Fraktion
linksliberalier die sagen die dann naja
also der März dieses Paschas das weiß
nicht so richtig gut aber der hat
natürlich schon einen kleinen Punkt und
dann denke ich immer und warum ist es
nicht möglich so was einfach dann offen
und laut auch mal in einer Sendung zu
sagen und darüber zu diskutieren und du
würdest dich wundern wer sich alles so
in diese Richtung äußert man wundert
sich wirklich aber die eigene Blase und
sozusagen die eigene Verordnung die
eigene Ideologie letzten Endes lässt es
nicht zu dann auch einfach mal zu
attestieren okay möglicherweise gibt es
da etwas ohne das Wort Paschas zu
benutzen gibt es dabei etwas über das
wir als Gesellschaft dringend mal
sprechen müssten und zwar übrigens auch
im Sinne dieser Kinder die es betrifft
weil wir tun den ja auch keinen Gefallen
ja im Sinne dessen dass wir die Themen
eben gerade nicht den Leuten die
ultimativ rechte Gesinnung haben
überlassen dürfen also wenn das Thema in
der Gesellschaft relativ wenig
angegangen wird wird es dazu dass nur
bestimmte Leute dieses Thema äußern
können und das sind dann häufig
diejenigen die dann tatsächlich starke
Vorurteile haben oder am Ende noch
rassistische Ideologien und so weiter
das heißt man kann diese Themen doch
nicht einfach denjenigen überlassen die
sich trauen das auszusprechen ja sondern
man wissen eine Kultur schaffen indem
man ganz normal und klar und sachlich
seine Meinung zu diesen Fragen und
diesen komplizierte Fragen sind
schwierige Fragen sind wichtige Fragen
für unsere Gesellschaft artikulieren
ohne Button ja richtig genau ohne diesen
diesen Rassismus oder AFD oder was auch
immer natürlich sagen und das weißt Du
eine die ganze Ukraine Diskussion wo es
Backen gab auf den Putin versteher stand
und was was ich was alles haben wir das
gleiche auch wieder gehabt also eine
differenzierte
Betrachtungsweise einer komplizierten
und schwierigen Frage der man sich dann
häufig entledigt indem man irgendwo
einen Button drauf klebt dann ist das
Thema erledigt also dieser Umgang mit
Buttons und jetzt können wir noch fünf
sechs andere Beispiele machen ja also
wenn man bestimmte Maßnahmen innerhalb
der corona-politik für falsch gehalten
hat dass man dann plötzlich Querdenker
Button aufgeklebt rechnet da hatten was
auch wieder wir müssen sehr vorsichtig
sein mit diesen Etikettierungen weil wir
zerstören damit unseren Debatten haben
wie gehst du denn damit um richte ich
habe neulich Anna Schneider von von der
Welt gelesen die die genau darüber
nachgedacht hat über diesen Applaus von
der falschen Seite diese Angst sozusagen
von Leuten Applaus zu kriegen die die an
z.B am äußersten rechten Rand unterwegs
sind oder vielleicht auch am äußersten
linken Rand unterwegs sind ja was auch
immer und sie schrieb an den
interessanten Satz und sagte ist mir
wurscht ist mir egal ist Wienerin nicht
wer etwas sagt zählt sondern was er sagt
und sagt dann weiter es gibt nicht sowas
wie eine kontaktschuld und es gibt auch
genauso wenig eine Gedanken oder
Kollektiv Schuld fand ich interessant
das ist absolut gut und präzise
ausgedrückt und man muss auch sagen wenn
ich mir bei jeder Äußerung die ich mache
immer von Anfang an die Schere im Kopf
habe irgendjemand von rechts oder
irgendjemand von links könnte darüber
jubilieren dann komme ich am Ende
überhaupt nicht mehr zu irgendwelchen
eindeutigen Aussagen also das kann ich
nicht machen also ich stimme dafür aber
es findet statt richtig ja das findet
statt und das findet in einem viel zu
großen Ausmaß statt und dann richtig
wieder was ich sage die Dialektik dieses
Prozess ist besteht darin dass die Leute
sich nicht mehr so richtig trauen zu
sagen was sie denken dass dieses
gedachte aber nicht weg ist sondern
quasi in den gesellschaftlichen
Untergrund wandert und das ist dann im
Zweifelsfall sich zu den Rändern bewegt
das heißt wir tun uns damit unter die
behaarte demokratischen Gesichtspunkt
unter dem Gesichtspunkt einer
bratschlagenden Öffentlichkeit ja mit
seiner Demokratie dazu gehört zu einer
Gesellschaft die den wohl meinen Streit
braucht tun wir uns keinen Gefallen mit
diesem Buttons sondern das ganze
verkehrt sich dann ins Gegenteil
du selber Richard hast du Angst davor
also wirst du wirst du dafür angegangen
und sagt ja ja das ist jetzt afd-sprech
was sie da gerade sagen oder das ist
irgendwie sind Gedanken die die sind
eigentlich so allgemein gesellschaftlich
geächtet beispielsweise jetzt mit AFD
sprechen wüsste ich nicht so konkret
aber ich weiß als ich damals gesagt habe
man soll keinen Druck auf Eltern ausüben
ihre Kinder zu impfen dass ich dann ins
quer den Karl Lager einsortiert wurde
und ich weiß gar nicht in einem Atemzug
wahrscheinlich auch mit der AFD oder so
genannt worden bin also das kann
durchaus vorkommen und das übrigens in
etablierten Leitmedien die für sich in
Anspruch nehmen Qualitätsstand ist zu
sein also man ist nicht gefeit davor
dass einem das passiert ist dir das
schon passiert ja denke an Carla rochl
von von der letzten Generation die die
bei uns saß und wir hatten sehr
intensives gutes Gespräch da war ich
dann plötzlich sozusagen ein ein Klima
Leugner ja ging dann plötzlich in diese
Ecke und das das fand ich damals sehr
sehr seltsam wir haben einfach nur
Argumente ausgetauscht wir haben hier
schon mal drüber gesprochen wer üben es
in dem Zusammenhang interessant ist ich
weiß nicht wie du sie erlebst Sarah
Wagenknecht ich bin mir mit Sarah
Wagenknecht in letzter Zeit so gut wie
nie einig ja einfach nie ja und trotzdem
spüre ich bei ihr immer eine große
Wertschätzung und die habe ich übrigens
auch ihr gegenüber ich habe eine große
Wertschätzung für Sie was sozusagen
ihre Person angeht ich habe eine
Wertschätzung durchaus für Sie wenn es
darum geht
sich zu bestimmten Themen zu
positionieren und dann auch das Argument
zu kennen und zu sagen da stehe ich
jetzt aber und da war ich auch keinen
Zentimeter von ab und das könnt ihr auch
alle doof finden aber ich bin trotzdem
bei dieser Haltung noch mal das muss man
alles nicht teilen und ich teile nichts
von all dem was ich sage wenn ich sage
Sahra Wagenknecht ist ein mutiger
erster Liniger und Hüft und höflicher
Mensch so ja das ja dann besagt das
nicht dass ich in allen Fragen mit ihr
übereinstimme sondern einfach Sachen
worauf ich sagen will dass alles das
meine ich ungeachtet der Frage wo ich
Übereinstimmungen habe und wo ich keine
habe
ich muss ja da sind wir wieder bei dem
was wir vorhin gesagt haben nicht jemand
als Person deswegen verurteilen weil er
in wichtigen Fragen anderer Meinung ist
richtig ja
kennst du
ilko Sascha kowalcuk der Historiker
vielleicht dachte vielleicht hast du ihn
schon mal getroffen ich kenne den auch
nicht es ist 55 Jahre alt so zwischen
uns beiden quasi geboren in der in der
damaligen DDR gehört hätte der
Kommission 30 Jahre friedliche
Revolution und deutsche Einheit an und
ähm die die bauen da gerade so einen ein
Zentrum auf sozusagen um die die Rolle
der DDR irgendwie auch besser zu
verstehen und aufzuarbeiten
und der hat neulich ein interessantes
Interview gegeben und vielleicht ist das
der Kern also sich ernsthaft mit den
Themen erstmal auseinanderzusetzen statt
immer nur so pauschal zu sagen also
diese ostdeutschen die sind alle so so
in denen ist die Demokratie irgendwie
suspekt und dann werden sie alle die AFD
und die haben irgendwie gar nichts
verstanden und undankbar sind sie
obendrein und so weiter wir hatten sehr
interessantes Interview gegeben und
sagte ein Fehler nach 89 war man dachte
Demokratie ist wirklich selbst erklärend
und das hat halt eben nicht funktioniert
und er weiß dann auf etwas hin und ich
dachte guck mal vielleicht ist da der
Schlüssel für einen besseren Diskurs für
einen besseres gegenseitiges Verständnis
er sagte wenn man an die Ausbildung von
Lehrerinnen und Lehrern denkt ne es gibt
in Deutschland ich wusste das nicht
keinen einzigen Lehrstuhl für die
Geschichte des Kommunismus auch die DDR
Geschichte wird an den Unis quasi ja
fast skandalös vernachlässigt wie er
sagt und sagt und deswegen kann der
Schule nicht vor genau und die sagten
deswegen können sich angehende
Lehrkräfte also mit der Geschichte des
Kommunismus im Grunde bei weitem nicht
so befassen wie es bei der NS-Geschichte
richtigerweise selbstverständlich ist
und deshalb kann man dann auch in der
Konsequenz an den Schulen nicht profund
über Kommunismus und die DDR reden oder
sagt und daher kommt dann auch zum Teil
dieses seltsamen verklärte was ist da so
gibt diese diese DDR Romantik weil es
eben vorne am am Lehrer Puls sozusagen
keinen gibt der mal wirklich kompetent
darüber reden kann das fand ich ein
total interessanten Gedanken zum Thema
Debattenkultur dessen interessanter
Gedanke mehr fällt natürlich zu dem
ostwestthema noch ein zweiter Gedanke
ein und ich will sehr hoffen dass ein
solches Zentrum das ebenfalls
thematisiert weil es auch so gut wie gar
nicht thematisiert wird aber mit
Sicherheit eine große Rolle spielt für
wichtige Mentalitäten Befindlichkeit und
Überzeugungen im Osten Deutschlands und
das hängt damit zusammen dass nach 89
und 90 die Wessis den Ossis erklärt
haben wer sie sind ja nämlich
rückständig gegenüber den Westies die
Verlierer in dieser ganzen
Auseinandersetzung ja wahrscheinlich
alle mehr oder weniger bei der Stasi
gewesen ja alles Mitläufer ja oder
überzeugt Idioten und so weiter das
heißt der Westen hat über den Osten die
komplette Deutungshoheit übernommen die
ostpolitiker die große Karriere gemacht
haben die Merkel und Gauck haben sich
genau in diese West dieses westenarativ
reingesetzt wir haben also keine Ost
Erfahrung mitgebracht außer zu sagen ja
wir wissen was Unfreiheit ist die aber
nicht gesagt haben wir wissen aber auch
warum die Leute sich so und so verhalten
haben und so verhalten sich Menschen
unter den und den Umständen und dass man
seine differenziertes Bild entworfen
haben wie das wirkliche Leben in der DDR
aus der Froschperspektive jedes
einzelnen zum Beispiel
stattdessen wurden sie damit
konfrontiert jetzt könnt ihr mal das was
er die letzten 40 Jahre gemacht habt
alle abhaken ja richtig und können mal
wieder neu anfangen weil bisher war
alles falsch und ich meine wenn man so
mit Menschen umgeht dann darf man sich
nicht wundern dass da eine enorme innere
Distanz aufgebaut wird richtig ja und
auch eine sehr großes Skepsis gegenüber
Erzählungen die einem übergestülpt
werden und das müsste man auch viel
stärker thematisieren ist total
interessant in diesem Gespräch macht
kovalcuk genau das auch zum Thema und
sagt es war der Westen der dieses
Nachdenken über die DDR und ja alles was
dieser Staat war verhindert hat und sagt
total interessant diese ganzen
Schlussstrich Forderungen ne jetzt muss
man Schlussstrich sein jetzt fangen wir
mal ganz von vorne an und wir wissen
aber wie es geht die kamen aus dem
Westen und interessanterweise auch das
war mir so nicht klar wobei ich jetzt
eigentlich besser wissen müssen weil ich
die Reaktionen häufig erlebe weißt du
woher die härtesten Reaktionen komme
wenn ich ich sozusagen versuche einen
kritisches Gespräch über die Linkspartei
und vor allen Dingen über ihr Erbe zu
führen SED PDS und dann Linkspartei die
härtesten Reaktionen kommen nicht wie
möglicherweise zu erwarten wäre aus dem
Westen dem sogenannten ja sondern die
kommen aus dem Osten und von niemandem
wurde genau diese Kontinuität ja also
einfach übergangslos von der SED in die
PDS und jetzt sind wir einfach die
Linkspartei und was eigentlich so unser
richtiges Erbe ist darüber reden wir
jetzt gar nicht mal so großartig von
niemandem wird das so scharf kritisiert
wie von den Russland sagt kowalcuk
wortwörtlich und das finde ich halt
interessant weil wir da offensichtlich
eine riesige Chance haben liegen lassen
auch wenn es um die Frage geht
die Kurs und und und wie wie nehmen wir
einander eigentlich wahr die hatten
durchaus ein großes Interesse das
aufzuarbeiten und sie haben es irgendwie
bis heute aber ich habe manchmal das
Gefühl auch wie als Medien wir werden
dem gar nicht so wirklich
und der sagt eben auch dass zum Beispiel
thematisiert werden muss dass es eben
nicht die Ostdeutschen waren die 89 die
Revolution gemacht haben sondern er sagt
Revolutionen machen Minderheiten und
auch in der DDR standen die meisten halt
hinter der Gardine haben abgewartet was
passiert und haben sich dann auf die
Seite der Sieger geschlagen so sagt erst
ja aber doch nicht völlig völlig
richtiger Beobachtung jeder Revolution
genau und er sagt das muss aber
thematisiert werden weil wenn wir dann
natürlich hinterher sozusagen alle zu
Widerstandskämpfern machen dann entsteht
so ein innerer Widerstand weil die Leute
sagen er warte mal aber das ist ja gar
nicht meine Geschichte ja gar nicht
meine Biografie und und die werden
sozusagen an dem Punkt auch entwertet
und fühlen sich auch nicht wirklich
verstanden
dazu dass die aller mutigsten ja das
waren die die als erste zu dem Thema
sind ja das waren die die wirklich was
riskiert haben denn solange es wenige
waren konnte man die einkassieren und
das war überhaupt nicht lustig wenn
Knast gekommen ist ab einem bestimmten
Punkt wenn also einmal auf dem
Alexanderplatz 100.000 mehr drauf sind
dann gehört nur noch halb so viel Mut
dazu zu gehen und jetzt macht man als
Ostdeutscher die interessante
Beobachterin das von den wirklich
mutigen der ersten Stunde aus keinem was
geworden ist
sondern dass die die nach der Karriere
machen wie Manfred Stolpe wie Gauk Wie
merke das waren die die erstmal ziemlich
lange hinterm Vorhand gestanden haben
und sich erst dann raus getraut haben
als klar war in welche Richtung sich das
ganze entwickelt und ich glaube das ist
nicht zu unterschätzen was das macht
wenn also nicht diejenigen die gefeiert
zurecht war sie gefeiert werden für
ihren Mut diejenigen sind die nachher
davon profitieren sondern eigentlich die
die gar nicht so gut ich gewesen sind
nachher als Aushängeschilder für den
guten Osten stehen
also dass vieles also man müsste diese
da wirklich mal eine differenzierte
Betrachtung machen und ich denke einfach
dass wir viel zu wenig verstehen dass es
sich aus Sicht des Ostens einfach alles
anders anfühlt als aus der Sicht des
Westens das ist der Punkt und deswegen
meinte ich gerade wenn es ja wir könnten
jetzt irgendwie die ganze Folge über
dieses ganze Gespräch über darüber
diskutieren wie schlimm das alles ist
und wie diese Lagerbildung stattfindet
und dass man nicht mehr miteinander
redet Erfinder viel interessanter ist
eigentlich mal zu überlegen was könnten
die Lösungen sein und ich finde was er
da vorschlägt zu sagen lass uns doch
wirklich systematisch auch Lehrstühle
für DDR Geschichte beispielsweise
aufbauen lass uns systematisch damit
beschäftigen dass natürlich ein sehr
konstruktiver guter Vorschlag weil er
einfach mal sozusagen eine Brücke baut
ja in in Richtung gegenseitiges
Verständnis ich meine ich finde das
spannend dass das jetzt so lange nach
der Wiedervereinigung erst diskutiert
wird
also ich bin in letzter Zeit viele in
Berlin lesen und da wir proben gehabt
haben in dem master-gebäude hinter dem
Schloss bin ich also Tag für Tag an
diesem Schloss vorbeigegangen was da
gebaut ist und wo früher der Palast der
Republik stand und dieses Schloss ist ja
von außen wunderschön genau wer von
ihnen ist es traurig ne es sieht also
eigentlich aus wie eine U-Bahn Station
überhaupt kein Reiz und keine Ahnung
fast nur Ausstellung drin die eigentlich
interessieren oder die hochproblematisch
sind so wie die Völkerkunde Ausstellung
die sich in erst in die mit sich selbst
beschäftigen muss
funktioniert als Forum überhaupt nicht
ist jetzt nicht der Platz wo am
Wochenende alle Leute hin strömen wie
früher in den Palast der Republik weil
es da für die Kinder Angebote gab und
für die Jugendlichen und so weiter und
so weiter also genau diesen Forum
Charakter erfüllt das ohne dass wir
jetzt den Palast der Republik hinterher
trauern naja ich traue ihm schon
hinterher nicht an der Funktion der in
der DDR allein gehabt hätte ja zwei
Funktionen er war ja eben ja in erster
Linie war ja tatsächlich in Ort wo man
als Berliner Jugend hingehen ja weil der
Konzerte stattfanden oder weil man alles
nicht so viel quasi eine riesige
Volkshochschule alles machen konnte
und wenn man sowas abreißt und anstelle
dann @ also ein es war in DDR-Zeiten
einerseits ein propaganda-bau dafür
übrigens ein harmloser ne also da gibt
es ja ganz andere Propaganda Bauten mal
gucken sich mal church Verlass an also
eigentlich ein sehr bescheidener
Propaganda Bau und auf der anderen Seite
war es tatsächlich ein echtes Forum und
das was man jetzt dahin gebaut hat ja
dieses von außen wunderschön aus musiale
Preußen Schloss ja ist ihnen tot
und ich finde das ist eine interessante
Metapher ja hier hat man versucht am
Reisbrett ein Forum zu entwerfen mein
Gott wie viele hunderttausend Leute
haben sich Gedanken darüber gemacht
haben da rein gequatscht bis am Ende
sowas Maus rausgekommen ist wie das was
ich da jetzt in dem Stadtschloss
abspielen wird die haben das nicht
hingekriegt müssen wir ganz ehrlich
sagen wir haben aber ein Stück DDR
Geschichte die nichtet wo ich mir
gewünscht hätte man hätte aus dem Palast
der Republik ein DDR Museum gemacht und
zwar in DDR Museum dass die DDR in allen
Seiten zeigt ja also einerseits
dargestellt wie sie sich selbst gesehen
hat dann die ganzen Schattenseiten Stasi
System Unterdrückung von Menschen mit
politisch andere Ansicht man hätte die
Alltagskultur in der DDR und darin
abgebildet das ganz normale Leben der
Menschen also alle Facetten die wirklich
zum DDR Leben dazugehören kein
schwarz-weiß-museum sondern eins das
alles zeigt aber auch nichts
ausspachtelt es wäre ein großartiger Ort
gewesen sich mit der der
auseinanderzusetzen meinte
wahrscheinlich die Lehrstelle gar nicht
gebraucht und ich deswegen jedes Mal
wenn ich an diesem sehr schönen Schloss
vorbeigehe denke ich immer was haben wir
aus der Mitte Berlins eigentlich gemacht
er ist spannend ich frag mich ja
manchmal ob man diesen Palast der
Republik nicht einfach hätte stehen
lassen soll ich meine jetzt mal
unabhängig davon was das für ein
unglaublicher Touristenmagnet heute wäre
aber auch als Ort der Erinnerung an ein
Symbol für für viel viel Unrecht das
darin geschehen ist beschlossen wurde
und so weiter als Ort an dem man
Geschichte noch mal erleben kann so viel
spannender als ein Stadtschloss dass er
so Las Vegas artig daherkommt ja ich
meine ich stelle mir vor bei den vielen
Touristen aus aller Welt die kommen
amerikanische Touristen zum Beispiel ja
die wären da alle reingeströmt ja in
Erichs Lampenladen und hätten das so
dermaßen so das war ja so seventies
rostig und so weiter ja also ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass das
Stadtschloss auch nur annähernd so viel
Besucher zieht ja wie der Palast der
Republik als DDR Museum mit weltweiten
Interesse gezogen hätte also ich muss da
immer an Karl den fünften denken es gibt
ja in Cordoba eine Moschee die Mesquita
und das flächenmäßig glaube ich die
größte Moschee der Welt die ist nicht
besonders hoch aber aber riesengroß und
da ist ihnen alles so mit so braun
weißen oder braunen gelblichen Gewölben
so Bögen also wie schwarz-weißgebäck
sieht das aus und er hat so ein ganz
tollen Zauber und dann geht man da rein
und mittendrin ist er auf einmal so eine
herkömmliche christliche Kirche die
haben sie mitten reingeknallt in diese
Moschee um die kaputt zu machen
so und dann hat man die stolz keinen
fünften gezeichnet wir haben die aber
verdrängt und jetzt haben wir dieses
tolle Dinge gebaut und guck mal jetzt
haben wir da eine ganz tolle christliche
Kirche eingebaut und Karl der Fünfte hat
gesagt
ihr habt etwas zerstört was einzigartig
war in der Welt und etwas da rein gebaut
was ist in dieser Form auch woanders
gibt
und das ist ein bisschen so also ich
meine Schlösser na klar dieses eine
Stadt Schloss gibt es nur einmal ja aber
es gibt sehr viele Preußen Schlösser und
auch schöne Preußen Schlösser und das
neue palaisoncé und so weiter
schalottenburg also es muss sie nicht
auch noch dieses Schloss gehen aber der
Palast der Republik ja als Sinnbild als
Symbol und dann mit dieser Architektur
diesen braunen verspiegelten Scheiben
genau wie man irgendwann in den 80er
90er Jahren wahnsinnig hässlich fand die
heute wieder totaler Kult werden ja in
dieser Traum in orange und Gold die das
im gewesen ist der Albtraum
da kommt dann wieder der deutsche Typ
ins Spiel das hätte man das hätte man
aber hinkriegen also ich glaube man hat
Berlin um seine größte
Touristenattraktion genau
so ein metallgedanke ein
wir werden ja auch schon mal
gelegentlich dafür kritisiert dass wir
uns über Dinge hier unterhalten von
denen wir eigentlich gar keine innere
Ahnung haben können weil wir selber
dieser Profession nicht angehören oder
jetzt reden wir die ganze Zeit über
Menschen aus dem Osten kommen beide
bekanntermaße nicht daher und das
Interessante ist immer in unserem
moralisierenden Debatten dass man immer
sagt wenn du selber kein Betroffener
bist dann darfst du nicht drüber
urteilen ist übrigens ein ganz
interessanter Teil unserer
Debattenkultur das heißt wenn du keine
Frau bist darfst du nicht über
Feminismus reden ja wenn du keinen
bekannt bist kannst du dir keinen Urteil
über Migranten
ja das ist natürlich gut dass unsere
Sensibilität in diesen Fragen sich
erhöht hat und wir gucken wer sagt das
aus welcher Perspektive heraus und warum
aber wenn wir immer grundsätzlich sagen
also ich habe mein Buch über die Schule
geschrieben ja unglaublich viele Lehrer
sich beschwert nach dem Motto der ist
doch gar keinen Lehrer ja wieso kann der
sich irgendwie überhaupt mein Bild
darüber anmaßen übrigens lustigste
Reaktion war der
ehemalige brandenburgische
Kulturminister ja der also ganz ganz
wütend über mich hergezogen hat und
gesagt wer also nicht mindestens 30
Jahre vor einer Schulklasse mit
Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund und
die die die lernschwach sind und was
auch immer gestanden hat er darf sich ja
wohl nicht erlauben ein Buch über die
Schule zu schreiben in dieser Minister
heute ist er das nicht mehr Herr
Brotkorb war damals glaube ich knapp 30
Jahre alt erst seit der hat also wenn
der 30 Jahre vor irgendeiner Klasse
erziehungsschwieriger gestanden hätte er
mir Null anfangen müssen der ist auch
nie Lehrer gewesen also diese diese
Vorstellung dass man immer nur dann sich
ein Urteil erlauben oder etwas
kritisieren kann wenn man selber in die
unmittelbare Betroffenen Gruppe gehört
das ist übrigens neben dem totalen
beleidigt sein ja eine zweite Seuche in
unserem Diskurs niemand dürfte mehr
Politiker kritisieren ja wenn er kein
Politiker ist keiner dürfte Journalisten
kritisieren wenn er nicht selbst Minde
mindestens 30 Jahre lang mal in der
Redaktionsstube da und da gearbeitet hat
das ist auch so ein grundgänger den wir
in unserer Debattenkultur haben der
immer weiter um sich greift und ich mich
frage wo soll das enden deine Bücher die
international auch mittlerweile
erschienen sind weißt du da immer genau
wer das übersetzt hat ob es eine Frau
war ob sie schwarz war ob sie weiß war
anders gefragt hättest du Grund
beleidigt zu sein oh ja ich hätte ganz
viele Gründe beleidigt zu sein also ich
habe einige Übersetzer also das Buch ist
in etwa 40 Sprachen übersetzt ich habe
nicht alle kennengelernt also meisten
asiatischen Übersetzer und
Übersetzerinnen natürlich nicht aber ich
weiß zum Beispiel deshalb eine ganz
nette Frau dir das Buch ins Albanische
übersetzt hat eine Frau ja da muss man
sich fragen kann eine Frau eigentlich
ein Mann verstehen und jetzt wird es
ganz kriminell also mein Buch ist
zweimal auf Englisch übersetzt einmal
für England einmal für die USA zwei
verschiedene Übersetzungen und die
Übersetzerin für die USA ist eine dunkle
Leute Frau
das ist natürlich moralisch grenzwertig
ja jedenfalls nach diskriminieren
ja nach Maßgabe heutiger Debattenkultur
übrigens muss man nach Maßgabe heutiger
Debattenkultur auch jetzt dazu sagen
Ironie ja sonst wird einem das wörtlich
aus dem Kontext gerissen und gegen einen
verwendet nein ich bin hoch erfreut
darüber dass es so ist ich finde es
großartig und ich glaube die
unwichtigste Frage beim Übersetzen eines
Buches ist es welche Hautfarbe man hat
welchem Kulturkreis man angehört und
welches Geschlecht man hat insofern man
die Sprache wunderbar beherrschen sich
gut rein versetzen kann ja das das der
entscheidende Punkt jetzt würden
natürlich sehr vocal Leute einwenden und
sagen ja ja ja du hast trotzdem keinen
Grund beleidigt zu sein weil du hast ja
keine Ahnung ich bin ich bin aus
biologischen Gründen Täter weil ich Mann
bin und weil ich weiß bin und weil ich
in einem
bestimmten Vokabular ausgedrückt
imperialistisch westlichen Landliebe so
und dann bin ich also absolut sozusagen
also solche Täter Biografie ich durfte
überhaupt gar nichts mehr sagen mit
einer solchen Biographie und jetzt kommt
ein Punkt auf jeden Fall langer Zeit mal
geht da nur hingewiesen hat und sich
damit sehr unbeliebt gemacht hat obwohl
er vollständig recht hat
jemanden eine bestimmte Lizenz in der
Debattenkultur abzusprechen aufgrund von
biologischen Dispositionen ist nicht
links sondern seit es Rassismus gibt
rechts
das muss man ganz klar dazu sagen also
linke machen niemand für etwas
verantwortlich was biologisch ist oder
wofür er nichts kann
sondern jemand aufgrund seiner Biologie
zu klassifizieren in diesem Fall Alter
weißer Mann ja ist ein klassisches
rechtes Argument in dem einfach nur
rumgedreht wird was die Rechten an
Rassismus denjenigen angetan haben die
keine alten weißen Männer sind
und es gibt ich ich lass den Gedanken
der Rache nicht gelten ja es ist keine
Gerechtigkeit dadurch hergestellt dass
man jetzt auf die gleiche Art und Weise
meint sprachlich zumindestens oder
sprach Polizei nicht mit Menschen
umgehen zu müssen wie man früher viel
schlimmer natürlich und viel konkreter
mit Menschen umgegangen sind die nicht
weiß sind und nicht Männer waren damit
ist niemanden geholfen also die
grundsätzliche Klassifizierung ja
aufgrund von Hautfarbe Alter und so
weiter als Täter oder Opfer
ist ein Biologismus richtig das kann man
auf gar keinen Fall machen ja damals
verstört man alles Positive linke was
man damit im Auge hat
die die diese Frage sozusagen dieses
ausgrenzen dieses Gefühl auch der der
Zugehörigkeit auf der anderen Seite ne
wie wichtig ist das was ist man immer
merkt ist und das ist hat zugenommen in
im Zeitalter sozialer Netzwerke da
drückt sich jemand erst mal ungeschickt
aus jetzt sind wir wieder bei Friedrich
Merz und den Herrschers ich würde ja
soweit gehen und immer sagen es darf
sogar sein es muss sogar sein dass ich
jemand mal ungeschickt ausdrückt weil
die Medien ja nichts worüber sich
aufregen kann und keiner hätte Grund
beleidigt richtig wie langweilig wäre
das denn richtig und Frieden nicht mehr
als würde wahrscheinlich dieses Wort
heute so nicht wiederholen sondern er
würde es irgendwie anders formulieren
aber der Punkt ist warum gestehen wir
Menschen auch Profis wie Friedrich Merz
können sich mal verbal vergaloppieren
warum gestehen wir das eigentlich
heutzutage keine mehr zu woher kommt
dieser dieser harte Moralismus der im
Grunde nur darauf lauert sind ja immer
diese drei Eskalationsstufen jemand
drückt sich ungeschickt aus dann wird
der absichtlich falsch interpretiert und
verstanden und dann ist die dritte Stufe
totale Vernichtung und zwar bis nichts
mehr von dir übrig bleibt zwischen
kommen noch die Stufe den die
Kontextualisierung ja Worte aus dem
Zusammenhang zu reißen und ihnen einen
Zusammenhang zu stellen indem sie
dreimal drastischer wirken als die
ursprünglich gemeint waren
ja genau und bis hin zu zur Vernichtung
das ist jetzt Friedrich Merzig passiert
nein und irgendwann versendet sich das
auch wieder aber es ist tatsächlich so
ich habe ja lange Zeit irgendwie
geglaubt dass die die
Entwicklungsgeschichte der Moral die
sensibilisierungsgeschichte der Moral
eigentlich habe ich die immer nur als
Fortschritt gesehen ne also wenn ich mal
gucke wie sind Menschen früher
miteinander umgegangen wir haben eben
gelernt unsere Kulturen haben gelernt
Frauen als gleichberechtigte Menschen
anzuerkennen wo sie sich also tausende
von Jahren schwer mit getan haben wir
gehen heute anders mit Kindern um als
wir das früher gemacht haben wir wir
achten heute viel sehr sehr viel mehr
genauer das kein Alltagsrassismus
stattfindet und so weiter also alles ist
ja eine positive Entwicklung und
gleichzeitig sehen wir in dem Maße indem
wir uns hier völlig zurecht und völlig
richtig weiter sensibilisiert haben das
auf der anderen Seite die Kultur der
Intoleranz gestiegen ist und dass dieses
Programm Artikel ich habe jetzt die
Lizenz ich muss immer nett sein ich muss
ganz genau aufpassen was ich sage aber
wenn jemand anders sich jetzt daneben
benimmt dann habe ich die Lizenz mit der
Keule drauf zu hauen das heißt also
diese ganz affektmodulation die ich in
meiner normalen Sprache haben muss ja
die ist ja von einer Sekunde auf die
anderen Weg wenn es ein öffentlich zum
Abschluss freigegebenes Opfer gibt dann
kann ich aber die Sau rauslassen das hat
deine Ventilfunktion je mehr wir uns
zusammenreißen müssen umso mehr freuen
wir uns dass wir uns da gehen lassen
dürfen und wahrscheinlich ist das so
zusammen
ich habe neulich langes Interview mit
eiert ACTA gelesen das ist der Präsident
des amerikanischen pennen toller
Schriftsteller
1970 geboren ungefähr so alt wie ich so
ein pakistanische Einwanderer mit Walkie
aufgewachsen viel prämiert
Schriftsteller und so weiter hatte einen
tollen Roman geschrieben
das war so das letzte was man so von ihm
kennt und hat vor einiger Zeit eine
echte Brandrede vor dem Pen in Berlin
gehalten und das die Überschrift war der
Trick ist zu reden ja und und sagt was
wir derzeit erleben ist absolut
verstörend wir leben in einer digitalen
Apartheid und dann sagt er und das fand
ich interessant wir wir können uns jetzt
furchtbar darüber aufregen dass Menschen
in ihren Blasen komische Dinge machen
und dass sie so rigide sind und dass wir
uns gegenseitig fertig machen dass wir
gar nicht mehr miteinander reden können
und nicht meines Gespräch kommen und
dass jeder sozusagen auf auf dem Recht
auf seine eigene Meinung behaart und
wenn man dann sagt gut du hast ein Recht
auf deine eigene Meinung aber du hast
keinen Recht auf eigene Fakten dann
sagen sie mir trotzdem egal und ich habe
trotzdem recht und das Ende immer in
einer Pizzeria oder im Keller einer
Pizzeria ein Washington wo dann Hillary
Clinton das Blut von armen Kindern
trinkt und so weiter und er sagte wir
müssen endlich verstehen
dass das ein Geschäftsmodell ist und wir
müssen statt uns mit uns selbst zu
beschäftigen und aufeinander loszugehen
sollten wir endlich mal verstehen was
die großen Mechanismen dahinter sind und
er sagt Facebook zum Beispiel
diese Atmosphäre entscheidend geprägt
also der meta-konzern ja zwischen zwei
14 und und zwar 19 oder eigentlich kann
man sagen bis jetzt sagt und es gab im
Jahr 2017 eine Metrik das wusste ich
nicht mit der man vorhersagen konnte wie
sich ein Post oder ein Kommentar
entwickeln wird das haben die haben die
sich ganz genau angeguckt MSM
downstreaming heißt das also gab es ein
internen Prozess um sozusagen zu
ermitteln haben sich die Programmierer
angeguckt welche Inhalte
verbreiten sich schneller in größerem
Umfang ja und und die haben dann
verstanden zwei 17 war das schon das ist
sozusagen bei Inhalten die besonders
brisant emotional die aber auch mit
Desinformation überladen sind das ist da
ganz besonders schnell geht und haben
dann sozusagen dieses Ding diese Idee
ganz großflächig ausgerollt und es gab
Entwicklers beschreibt er da bei
Facebook die haben eine Facebook-Seite
gestartet einfach eine leere
Facebook-Seite nichts drauf geschrieben
komplett leere Seite und dann zugeguckt
was passiert und er sagt innerhalb von
zwei oder drei Tagen in denen sie die
Entwickler nichts getan haben war diese
Seite komplett mit Desinformation
überflutet das heißt dieses
Geschäftsmodell dass da dahinter ist das
sozusagen mit mit Desinformationen mit
spektakulären News mit Lügen Geld
verdienen wird ich glaube er hat Recht
dass wir darüber viel zu wenig
diskutieren dass wir das viel zu wenig
in den Fokus rücken und dass wir
stattdessen auch da wieder wir gehen
aufeinander untereinander gehen wir
aufeinander los sozusagen aber wir
beschäftigen uns nicht mit denen die
dahinter die ganz große mag oder den
großen Euro den großen Dollar mit genau
dieser Mechanik machen
[Musik]
also insgesamt ist natürlich die die
erregungskultur ein ein gigantisches
Geschäft allerdings natürlich nicht erst
seit das soziale Netzwerke gibt sondern
seit es yellopress gibt und Boulevard
Presse also im Grunde um so lange wie es
Presse gibt ja aber das ist jetzt eine
andere Dimension ne ist eine völlig
genau das genau also das Geschäftsmodell
ist im Prinzip das gleiche dass man dass
man mit Erregung mit Aufregung Geld
verdient ne damit ist die Bild-Zeitung
groß geworden auch mit einem relativ
lockeren Blick auf Fakten auch damit ist
die Bild-Zeitung groß geworden also Fake
News sind ja keine Erfindung des
Digitalzeitalters aber dass man jetzt
das ganze unglaublich
professionalisieren und systematisieren
kann und dass da natürlich ein Hummus
herangegereift ist den niemand mehr
wirklich tatsächlich kontrollieren kann
es gibt ja viele
es gibt ja viele nur als als sozusagen
verhindert dazu Direktor es gibt ja ganz
viele berühmte Experimente mit Ratten
und du kennst das und ich habe neulich
darüber gelesen das Experiment mit
Ratten die sich selber sozusagen
stimulierende Kicks verabreichen konnten
mit angeschlossenen Karten kennst du das
die die an über den neurokortex ja Kabel
angeschlossen und die können sich so
selbst stimulierende Kicks verabreichen
und es passiert folgendes diese Tiere
geraten in eine irre Erregung Schleife
regen sich immer weiter auf putschen
sich sozusagen immer weiter hoch hören
irgendwann auf zu fressen und zu trinken
und und sterben schließlich und die
Frage ist haben sie eine Übererregung an
überregung genau du bist die ganze Zeit
nur noch mit dieser erregungsspirale
beschäftigt weißt du nicht ich frage
mich manchmal ob wir nicht vielleicht
genau diese Ratten sind und Mark
Zuckerberg sitzt im Keller und macht ab
und zu mal den Strom an das sind schönes
Bild ja also es gab ja von Nil Posten
immer das Buch ne wir wir amüsieren uns
zu tun genau ja und ich habe meine Messe
vor zehn Jahren darüber gesprochen ob
wir uns irgendwie zu nicht zu Tode
erregen und aufregen also ob der dieser
dieser Mechanismus nicht am Ende dazu
führt dass man über alles den Verstand
verliert und damit natürlich auch seine
verständnisfähigkeiten richtig also es
gibt den Lessings Emilia Galotti geht er
sagt die Gräfin Ursina wer über
bestimmte Dinge den Verstand nicht
verliert hat keinen zu verlieren ja und
ich möchte auf Lessing drauf Reimen der
über alles den Verstand verliert hat
auch keinen mehr Zufall richtig ja das
heißt also sozusagen der angebissene
Umgang mit der eigenen Aufregung und
Erregung das ist etwas was im Leben
unglaublich wichtig ist es wäre schön
wenn man das irgendwie schon lernen
würde in der Schule aber das wirklich zu
den zu den Fähigkeiten gehört die man
ein Leben lang gut gebrauchen kann also
aristoteles hat schon gesagt ne sich
aufzuregen ist einfach ja aber sich so
richtigen Zeit über das richtige
aufzuregen das ist schwierig das setzt
urteilskompetenz voraus und ich denke
dass wir diese urteilskompetenz dass das
ist dasjenige ist was in unserem
Bildungssystem am stärksten
vernachlässigt wird weil es nicht im
Mittelpunkt des Systems steht das ist
etwas woran man dann am Ende
unterscheiden kann ob diese Gesellschaft
wie deine Ratten endet oder nicht ja
wird davon abhängen wie sehr es ihr
gelingt ihre Urteilskraft zu schulen in
einer
hyperventilierenden Gesellschaft ja und
das ist unheimlich schwer wenn eine Lüge
wie ich gerade beschrieben habe ja wenn
die Lüge plötzlich zum Geschäftsmodell
wird und das erleben wir das sagen ja
auch Leute wie harari z.B der macht sich
auch viele Gedanken darüber ja der sagt
jetzt Sensor der Vergangenheit hat
sozusagen sein voll kontrolliert indem
man die Leute doof gehalten hat
abgeschnitten hat von Informationen der
Zensor des 21 jahrhunderts kontrolliert
eine Bevölkerung indem sie zu müllt mit
Lügen und das Information ja nicht so
dass die Leute irgendwann nicht mehr
wissen wo oben und unten ist und wo
sozusagen die Wahrheit ist und das
bedeutet
eine Einschränkung würde ich machen ich
würde sagen das haben früher Regime auch
immer alles gemacht nicht in der
gleichen Menge aber die Leute waren auch
durch weniger Informationen ja stärker
erreichbar es ist ja klar ne du hast
diese erregungsökonomie und wenn es
wenige Dinge gibt die du hörst ich meine
diese ganzen furchtbaren
verschwörungserzählungen ja der
Antisemitismus der Rassismus und so
weiter das sind ja Dinge die quasi auch
mehr oder weniger von staatswegen
verbreitet wurden als Propaganda was hat
man den den Leuten im deutschen
Kaiserreich nicht alles erzählt wie
minderwertig die Sklaven und die
Franzosen nur wer sonst noch alles ist
und wie grandios die Deutschen sind und
die überlegen und noch viel schlimmer im
Dritten Reich und die Engländer haben
dass ihre Bevölkerung auch erzählt
gerade im Hinblick auf die Kolonien und
so also dass man mit Fake News und
Propaganda von Staats wegen zugemüllt
wird ist ja nichts neues das ist richtig
nur heute ist es so dass es
millionenfach milliardenfach mehr
Informationen in der Welt gibt und
deswegen muss man das nicht einmal
machen sondern man muss natürlich mit
enorm auf Frequenz ja mit enormes
skalierungseffekten diese Fake News in
die Welt bringen aber das Starten lügen
ist nun wirklich nicht neu ja aber die
die Werkzeuge die sie dafür zur
Verfügung haben sind so unfassbar
mächtig wenn du auch noch mal Akte ja
der der sagt wir müssen endlich über
über diese unternehmensmacht müssen wir
sprechen in den USA zum Beispiel ja die
wirklich global agieren und der weiß
weist auf etwas hin das fand ich sehr
interessant sagt ein Präsident wie
Eisenhauer z.B der hat den Amerikaner
noch gesagt ihr müsst z.B dem
militärisch industriellen Komplex
gegenüber
das das hören wir heute nicht mehr
misstrauisch sein diesen großen
Unternehmen gegenüber dem Militär
oder eine Rede halten und sagen ihr
müsst gegenüber die militärische
industriellen Komplex gemeint ist dass
die Rüstungsindustrie die mit
Riesenabstand größte Wirtschaftszweig
der USA ist und eine gigantische
politische Macht hat den gegenüber
skeptisch sein also ich meine wir machen
uns nichts vor er ist mit denen im Bunde
ist nicht deren natürlicher Feind
ja und die Frage ist aber wenn es diese
Macht dieser Konzerne gibt wenn wir
gerade festgestellt haben dass die Lüge
ein Geschäftsmodell geworden ist wenn es
diesen gigantischen
militärischindustriellen Komplex gibt
und man hat das Gefühl Regierungen
Dackeln da irgendwie nur noch so
hinterher und versuchen verzweifelt dass
irgendwie wieder in den Griff zu kriegen
wie zitieren ich weiß noch was das für
ein komisches Gefühl war als als das
plötzlich anfing auch in den großen
seriösen Nachrichtensendungen wie weit
Twitter berichtet wird und Facebook und
und jeder sozusagen also nichts
kuratiertes mehr sondern allen
Algorithmus entscheidet darüber
ob das jetzt
begleitet wird oder nicht aber das
durchläuft keinen großen redaktionellen
Prozess mehr da sind keine Journalisten
mehr JournalistInnen ja die eine Auswahl
treffen die das Einordnen die es
kontextualisieren und wir haben immer
angefangen das mit der allergrößten
Selbstverständlichkeit so zu zitieren
ich dachte immer aber warte mal wir sind
doch sonst immer so wahnsinnig wenn sie
in Richtung Werbung geht ja und wenn es
in in Richtung sozusagen Vermengung geht
ja von von werblichen mit relationellen
Inhalten da passen wir immer wahnsinnig
auf und das lernen wir alles schon im
volont und dann gehen wir plötzlich hin
und zitieren kommerzielle amerikanische
Unternehmen mit der größten
Selbstverständlichkeit und das
hinterfragt kein Mensch mehr warum nicht
Richard
weil wir keine Alternative wissen
weil man in früheren Zeiten gegen solch
eine macht ein Mittel gehabt hat und das
war unter dem Gesichtspunkt der
Kartellbildung zerschlagungen zu
betreiben um solche ungeheure Macht zu
brechen wir Amerikaner haben das ja sehr
oft gemacht die haben teilweise mal die
Filmindustrie zerschlagen sie haben die
telefonindustrie AT&T zerschlagen sie
haben mir die Ölindustrie zerschlagen
Standard Oil also das ist das das
klassische Mittel also selbst ein ein
durch und durch kapitalistisches Land
benutzt das Mittel der Zerschlagung wenn
es das Gefühl hat dass die Märkte in
eine solche Schieflage geraten dass sie
nicht mehr funktioniert und jetzt haben
wir die Situation in der
digitalwirtschaft das jemand wie Google
ist ja kein Marktteilnehmer der
Wissensökonomie ja und einmal sind es
auch kein Marktteilnehmer des online
handelts sondern es ungefähr die Hälfte
des globalen online online Handels ist
Amazon ja und Google die größte Teil der
Wissensökonomie das ist das eine das
heißt also im Grunde genommen sind aus
Teilnehmern selbst Märkte geworden das
ist eine ganz neue Entwicklung auf die
man überhaupt noch keine Antwort hat und
das zweite ist dass man im Zeitalter der
digitalwirtschaft nicht mehr im
altmodischen Sinne Konzerne zerschlagen
kann um ihre Macht zu brechen sondern
das wäre überhaupt nichts verändert wenn
es fünf Googles gäbe ja oder wenn wenn
Amazon nicht auflösen würde in drei oder
vier Firmen in die verschiedene Sparten
macht ja beim solange man die Daten
heimliche oder offiziell untereinander
austauscht und so weiter wird das kein
Unterschied machen dass wir wissen
überhaupt noch gar nicht wegen wie wir
gegen diese im Zweifelsfall jederzeit
hoch manipulative macht überhaupt etwas
ausrichten können uns fehlen die Waffen
aber so weit so düster dann dann dann
würde ich sagen Richard dann enden wir
doch mit einem schönen Satz ich habe den
neulich schon mal cd-drucker Williams
WWW waren sein letztes nicht vollendetes
Buch
woher schreibt wie Erwachen im Goldenen
Zeitalter der ruhelosen und wir werden
sagen können wenn wir den Städten auf
die Straßen traten hatte der Kampf um
unsere Aufmerksamkeit schon eingesetzt
und ich finde das ist ein guter Gedanke
selbstkritisch bleiben dass im
Hinterkopf habend kann man dann noch
deutlich entspannter auf die Straße
treten wenn man diese großen
Zusammenhänge kennt und versteht ja also
wenn man Herr seine eigenen
Aufmerksamkeiten würde zumindestens zu
einem gewissen Teil dann wäre schon eine
Menge gewonnen weil das nicht einfach
also wirklich er dank dir sehr viel Spaß
ja
alles Gute tschüss
eine Produktion von zwei und Pots bei
OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]